okay hello everyone welcome to a
software design review this is a
language completeness and consistency
meeting about as always well from
language
and looks like we have three topics here
let's start off talking about the output
size limiter
uh okay
right you wanna
we've been working on the redesign so
it's been a few months since you last
saw this but we we think this is the
final version it looks pretty good to me
i mean so
this is is this is this live
well
that that one isn't because it's from a
previous kernel session but if you just
reevaluate it and how do i know that
currently if you click on any of those
it'll let you know that
does it what could it know at the stage
where you're actually doing the clicking
could it already upgrade it somehow or
is it not worth it
um
it can probably detect the case when
you're in a new kernel session it won't
be able to detect the case
that someone has been mucking about with
dollar history length
or clearing dollar or clearing out
or things like that
but i could investigate at least
detecting the new kernel session
yeah okay so i mean then it could say
this size in memory is irrelevant right
and by the way please make make it not
say eight point
understood
the
we need a general way to do that do we
have a general function that does the
right thing with formatting numbers that
doesn't leave a trailing point even when
it's decimal when it doesn't need one
i'm not aware of one
it's a question for nick and jose
i was thinking i don't think we have one
i think we need one i was i was suddenly
wondering if of course alpha has one or
if alpha does not have one it might be
that alpha turns it into 8.0
that would be my guess
well but the alpha goes the other way
doesn't it
it turns eight point zero into eight
oh well let's just see
yeah but but
be that as it may
we now have decimal form and all those
kinds of things i think we need a
a good default form which in cases of
output like this just does it
automatically
we have implemented that in percent form
but i think that's the only one okay
well let's have a general way of doing
it i mean what should it be called
um
can we try and look through number form
and decimal form and so on
and also
you know when you insert this in
a
string arguably the insertion function
should automatically do this
do you see what i'm saying
i mean i've had to change this so many
millions of times
i don't think i should have to
i'm making sense
i don't think you're making sense i mean
you understand whenever you do tostring
it should magically strip out the no
string template
hello back tick back
tick comma
list
five point
what i would say to do that
well i what do i want to do i just want
to say five point
okay i don't know how it came to make it
5.0 it's nice actually
i wonder how it made it 5.0
do you understand what i'm asking
i
and and the short answer is i i don't
know how straight string i think i
suspect that it's using that famous um
uh
i mean it may be using number form with
you know no i don't think no it's
probably using that text
right the the the function that
magically turns your number into um
it's using text
okay so let's take a look
at what
you know the second example there
yeah
and brett's right about alpha and so
carl would be the person to talk to if
you if that's code that you want to
steal
which i mean i have to say the alpha
behavior drives me nuts
right but of course because i do you
know control equal 1.0 meters
um and it turns it into one meter and
now i have an exact computation where it
wasn't what i wanted
yeah
ouch
and that's right and i agree with you i
think i think the conversion to wolfram
language input form shouldn't be the
same as the conversion to display form
right so right which is a point i i was
about to make which is you know i don't
know if that eight
in that megabyte is at all selectable if
it's not selectable it's it's not an
issue but
you know we can make we can strip the
period
and it's not an issue but if it's
something that might be copied and then
used as input then you know there's a
semantic difference between the dot and
not dotted versions
but if it was using string template then
this should have eight point zeroed it
which would have been just fine
right
so i don't know how it generated the
eight
point and string
well probably just right that's probably
just like a row or a quantity a row of a
quantity
so the thing that we we're not
understanding correctly
is that string template does something
different
which is probably the right way to
insert text into uh sorry numbers into
text
and these other things are sort of hacky
but i mean i've needed this a million
times in in for example
uh axis labels
okay things like that
and i have to say that by the time you
are outputting it as a string
you typically don't want the trailing
period i mean right but that's not
that's not a string right that's a
quantity object
right you can't see that as a quantity
object right but that right that's not a
string i see but the issue is when is
something like an axis label
basically not even selectable not
copyable
and just something that
you know is for human visibility only so
to speak in those cases you want to drop
the trailing period in the case where it
is selectable or you copy it then you do
want the trailing period
right
okay so that's that's that's right
yeah i'm not sure string template always
does the right thing because if you do
um three quarters
um it turns it into 0.75 that's very bad
probably
yeah i agree that's bad that that's
that's in the category of not well
it it probably isn't so bad because most
of the time it you you want something
very stringified like that but okay
basic point here this is a
quintessential lcc topic
of how do we make it so that there is a
way to get
sort of
number presentation
in such a way that if the number is
merely being presented
axis labels strings whatever else
it has
sort of for human pleasantness only
reading
only if it is something that is copyable
or reusable should it have the full
you know dot plumage and so on
does that make sense
right but i mean right people can
construct you know grids of
arbitrary expressions right i mean that
can't go in and read that so what's
what's human presentation is i don't
know
but i mean it is
right so we're gonna need two things
we're gonna need a function
that is a form
that says show numbers in a humanly
pleasant way
that's point one and point two we're
gonna need to go through and look at
places where we can obviously say like
if it's a pure string or a plot label or
something like this where we can
obviously say you don't want the the uh
the extra plumage
that makes sense
maybe
okay
let's let's analyze what the function
that does this should be we don't have a
name for it yet
but can we please look at the
constellation of functions between text
string decimal form number form and so
on that might go around it and let's
bring back a proposal for that
and then let's also bring back a
proposal for when that function should
be auto used in other places
that seem fair
sure it could be an option in number
form like num we have number point some
value for number point
yeah that's not a bad idea to begin with
it could certainly be there
that would be the the heavily controlled
version i think that we'll need
something which is a much simpler to use
kind of immediate way to do this but
that sounds like a very good place to
start
right with other number
cases we had the options in number form
and then we created the specific version
with a default like this i agree i agree
right so this is something like
uh you know include trailing point or
something
or or maybe you know
number point goes to
i don't know if automatic already has
some meaning but
uh
that's a reasonable idea as well
number point well it's a little weird
because that's kind of telling you what
the number point is going to be
and no you see that's not going to work
because you you're saying in that case i
want the number point to be a comma
you know for
european continental european numbers
but i also want it to not appear when
it's an integer so i don't think that
can be stuffed into the same option
yeah it has to be a separate option
i think um
you know include number point
arrow
true false
well i don't know what the heck false
means false just means
i i don't really know something like
that though it's it's i agree it's right
it's probably
trailing number point goes to true false
with you know
the current behavior and false being
there is a value already in number point
goes to automatic and it may be exactly
this can you
look at the documentation for a moment
huh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so that's probably been there since
version two or thereabouts
yes
i think it might even well yes probably
about version two
by the way a very very very picky point
but in these trailer-like trailing lines
shouldn't there be more space around the
vertical bar there just as the to make
it at least as much space as there is
around the bullet
so anybody here who's relevant to that
well jeremy should be here so he jeremy
d should be here um
you at least see what's inside philly is
so billy could you take that please
yes
um
okay
well what do you know oh my gosh all
these years
so okay
my basic point is number f number point
our automatic should be inserted in plot
label stuff etc etc etc
okay and we might need a wrapper that
does this
um
what should it be called almost integer
form
simple form
i was going to say
that i've
suggested this to i think itai and jose
recently
that in a lot of cases
this is contextual that you don't
necessarily want to make that
determination
based on just the single numbers but on
a set of numbers
all together
i don't think you ever want i think you
might want 5.0
you know 5.0 4.5 you know whatever it is
exactly that's good but but in the case
what i never want to see
is 4.5 five point
never want to see that
so brett i think it's up to you to try
and fix this for graphics
okay
that makes sense
um i i i report it where i see it you
know to whoever's you know whether
that's my team or front end or i i'm
suggesting that somebody do a bit of a
more systematic look at this
okay
or do i have to do it no i don't think
you have to do it but i'm not sure
you know
if if if somebody says plot label goes
to some row construct
that's a different case i mean and
in that case okay there's the question
of whether one should have an outer
number form
around there that tries to prevent these
things from being generated that's an
interesting question i think the answer
is probably yes
but
and if you do really want it generated
you can put a number form in there
yourself to switch this off but i do
think that we need
a um
what would be a you know we want la form
what's the blah
stephen
i'm not the only person
um
well i suppose we could have decimal
less form
i i don't know that that's actually
weird but it's um
chop form
oh that's not a bad idea bad
chopped form
i like that idea
because it does do something very
similar to what chop does
right so this is basically number form
only it defaults to number point goes to
automatic
i think so pretty much yes
and and in fact nicely i mean it isn't
quite
well right chocolate chop just does
things to zero right there i suppose it
would be rounded form
if you want the the strict analogy right
because round will be the thing that
will turn that 5.2
uh
i mean the the only problem with rounded
is that sounds like you know
semi-circles
right but you know making your corners
well not just that but um
chopped
is more apt because um it's not touching
5.2 whereas rounded would turn that into
a 5.
i guess that's true
well i think provisionally chopped form
is kind of nice
i mean i think it's i think it's
certainly comprehensible even if it's
you know a slight variation on the true
chop
function
another suggestion sorry somebody was
about to suggest something else
um
so what about the the original
point that this is not going to work in
with commas for example
should we have number point goes to coma
coma automatic i think so
it's not obvious we shouldn't enhance
number four with a separate orthogonal
option
can you guys just have a think about
that and then and then let's
introduce we've got three things here
we've got hunting down graphics
functions and other things and other
places like this where we display
you know numbers right
and deciding like like for example in a
preferences in a
in a
in a
progress monitor right you're typically
going to want to pick a certain number
of digits and stick to it
even if maybe you don't actually know
because it's like
0.1 megabytes downloaded 0.2 then 7.6
324.2 and so on
you could i don't know when you want to
get what i'm saying i'm not we don't
want to be flashing you know eight
well actually
maybe it's not so bad i mean eight 8.5 i
don't know
we just need to inventory these
different cases
fair
okay now let's come back to the original
question
right
okay so i've got an objection here
when this isn't actually in memory
the
uh
i could say original size and memory but
right it's not it's not like we always
know right if somebody decides to
suddenly change dollar history lengths
right it's not like
[Music]
and i don't think we want the dynamic
they're continually asking oh is
is this history still valid
[Music]
look
the two cases the three cases okay
we know it's okay
we know it's toast and we don't
know okay
are all those cases distinguishable
do we ever actually know that it's okay
what would make it not okay
a change in the assignments for out
which we could tag separately
uh
right well if dollar history length is
finite
right it'll go out of scope
okay fine
i'm perfect honestly i don't think
people have had finite dollar history
length since the days of no you're wrong
people regularly use
finite history lengths
okay
maybe i should too i know i was just
gonna say people
you know rightly or wrongly
think it's secure for a lot of things
hmm
okay
i only do or either full or zero to for
testing of memory
yes
okay but in any case i mean
the point that i'm making is a lot of
those controls like if the thing really
is a dead animal here and nothing can
bring it back to life
it's really unfortunate it's got a giant
row of controls where every controller
is going to say sorry you're out of luck
but certainly after the first press and
the first failure we know
oh that's true
but i mean you also know
to my mind having something having a
hook
that
does dollar history length actually work
inside
isn't there something which it knows at
the time when it's doesn't it have to
actually explicitly clear and out
do you understand what i'm saying
[Music]
i
i don't remember it's i i would have to
look at the code um i mean obviously
obviously when you change it it might
need to clear things out
but
in in the you know if it's constant i'm
not sure exactly how that
how that goes
okay
and the down values about are not
protected in any way users could
selectively delete them
okay fine yeah
all right
however if it's a different session id
we know it's toast
right
okay so i think we we've got two cases
different session id well three cases
different session id it's already been
pressed and it's it's been discovered to
be toast and
a we think it might still be edible
bread
yep
okay
all right so let's look at what we do in
those cases okay let's say we know it's
toast
what do we do what would we like to do
do we want that bar there at all
or
you know
created in a previous session or
something
creating a previous session
it's really what we have to say because
none of that's going to work is it
no
okay i mean i think it's better to say
you know original expression not
available and okay that's fine
and and that will uh apply equally to
the case where
we thought it was still there and then
you pressed it and oops it it actually
went away as to the
you know different
you're now in the new session okay will
we still know the original memory size
yes
okay then why don't we say original
expression not available
uh
oh just say full expression not
available
paren original memory size blah blah
blah
okay
all in that gray the same gray we don't
need to redden it or
no i wouldn't yeah don't run it i mean
just it's like okay it is what it is
now
um graphic design wise
okay
okay so it knows this error message
comes about in the case where it should
come about okay so those are that's the
case where we okay so either if you
press it or
it was known to be dead that's what we
do okay fine
for some reason it's bothering me
slightly there's this bigger space here
um why is that our biggest place
yeah if you could come in a little bit
yeah i think that's on me i'll
i'll
equalize those spaces
thank you
what the hell's this that's some new bug
i shouldn't worry about that that's the
13th there's a there's a known issue
oh it's interesting
and of course you're in the prototype
build so you know there may be some
experiment in there that's
doing crazy things
is there a reason the font is so light
for those numbers
did yeah i was wondering that too
i think the idea is that when you press
the store full expression it
darkens up a little bit yeah it was
specified as with with partial
transparency to give the sense of this
isn't really here
um but it's not bad the next button over
steven store full expression
changes the browser
i love that
how would i name that iconized
expression
that's been installed right the the well
at least the last time we discussed this
right it was going to be attached to
a selection raft but selection rafts
were displaced by other front-end
features
so um i mean basically
what you would need to do is like wrap
that in iconize and give it a second
argument with the name and evaluate in
place
which is kind of ugly but that that's
what's available
at this instant in time yeah okay so
it's ugly so we don't like that but
but um
so what does i can eyes expression do
i see i think that should be renamed
i think that should say i can eyes
expression in place
okay what do you think do what do other
people think
i mean i think it's right it's not
different from the selection right if
you type some input and then you select
it and right click or look at the yeah
then it says
expression
right so
i know but it's just a little weird that
it it you know it feels okay well let's
see if i say show more here
oops i need another one
is it in fact going to x lines
every time
it's going to i think roughly 2x it's
calling short with
double the size that it called it last
time whether that translates to 2x times
is up to short
right then obviously if you have very
complicated expressions inside then
short's ability to estimate the actual
number of lines will be limited
okay
all right now obviously the thing i'd
really really like to see is for us to
make this active somehow
i think we should have a separate
project perhaps even on the project list
to do with the lighted expressions
i don't know whether lou has comments on
this
um sounds like a useful thing to figure
out
well it's something we've been talking
about for 20 years
i'm not entirely sure what you mean by
making that active
well i mean that you can click on it to
get more stuff there so that for example
you could have
the
rather than a lot of this stuff you
could just click on that and it would
let you because that's the place where
you want to go you say i want to see
more here
not i'm going to go down to the bottom
and see because by the time i've got
multiple screens here it's very
inconvenient to go back and say right
yeah so in the case where you have
multiple
dot dots then you want to say make this
dot
bigger okay exactly and and also with
short
yes it's very common to end up with
something where you have lists and then
one shortened thing comma list and then
two other shortened things and it's like
i want to see the third one let me just
let me click on that one to see more of
it
that's pretty common thing to see in
output
all kinds of different kinds of output
i mean short often
has multiple iconized pieces is what i'm
saying
yep
okay
let's see what happens if i do this
right so now it changed color because
it's really really there
so you know if you could quit the kernel
and then you could evaluate that output
expression i think the buttons would
work too right
or
they they do yes yes
i find this border very
uh
unduly thick
can we just make it thinner
okay
i mean
i just don't understand why it's quite
so thick
right i mean we don't want it to be too
thin right because we're trying to
contrast it with the ethereal
but i agree that it could maybe be a
smidge
could we mark it with like half the
width or something
um
okay a comment from our live stream from
nihil
uh pointing out that if we have a better
summary of what number point goes to
automatic does we should put it in the
documentation absolutely
no actually it's not terrible what's
there
but
and i can also imagine in modern times
well i don't know i i
just we gotta dig into this particular
thing and check all the consequences and
so on
um
okay and ethan says
did you improve the truncation display
for expressions of high levels of
nesting
i'm sorry to say i suspect the answer
that is no i suspect that that's still
using the old short technology
am i correct
i know
i don't i don't think anything has been
done with that
i think that's code that i wrote a very
very long time ago the short code i
it's disappointing that it hasn't been
updated
okay in any case
uh
well the the code in box forms was not
written by you that's correct oh that
yeah only only the input the only the
output form stuff yeah
but i keep on being told how hard a
problem is but i know i solved that
problem for output form and it was
tricky it was somewhat tricky it uses
some you know amounts of energy or
something and it passes these energies
down with certain weights and all that
kind of stuff
right but output form doesn't need to
doesn't need to know
has access to all the available
information which is you know the the
current uh line with and that's it
whereas
you know
the if there are template boxes the
kernel may not even really know
how something is displayed much less how
how big the front end will render yeah
that's an ugly thing
we we should have a discussion segment
at some point maybe in an lcc meeting
about the future of short
okay okay
and and what the actual issues are
and whether in modern times with all the
new ux stuff that we have and all the
new kinds of boxes we have maybe there's
a different way to handle it
i mean you know here's here's a point
that i would like to make
if we had micro
you know
uh micro opening
we could get away with much less
wonderful
kind of choice of where to put the
illusion i think
otherwise if we'd sprayed multiple
illusions in here okay if you can just
go in and say well i want to open that
illusion great fine we we closed some
illusion more than we should have closed
it
but
at least it's easier to revert
if that makes sense
and it might make it easier to do this
if we just say you know if somebody's
worried oh well you know it um
making sense the the um
uh
um
um
okay
let's see
all right so here
stored in notebook 8 megabytes that
looks fine
yeah
and i can eye still works that's all
good
up billy has actual
examples here
i don't know if i made it too thin now
that i'm looking at the live stream
again oh man it got bigger for some
reason on
well i don't know
whoops
i don't know whether this
i don't know why it does that okay
i like the dark the middle one
really why don't you like this one this
one seems fine to me i mean this is an
expression it's got
it's fine and you know
well to me it just seems a bit too light
i mean i can't even necessarily like
underneath where it says
original gray i can't even really tell
that there's still a line there
i can infer that it exists but like yeah
well okay i think that's an artifact of
what you see over there because it looks
just fine to me
i think this one is going to be the
winner now the only question is whether
this double line down here makes any
sense
i also think that stored in notebook is
way too big there
you know that right
that font size
needs to be this font size not this font
size
yeah there's some weird magnification
thing going on
okay don't capitalize all the words we
don't want that full expression will not
cap all the words
the original size and memory don't cap
those
and um
i i like the idea of doing this
yeah i wouldn't make it that
i like the idea of dot yo you're dotting
it here this is good yeah that seems
fine
all right so this is my suggestion now
the double lines
they look a little weird to me
jeremy i think they were
originally your suggestion
um
[Music]
okay this is one of these things where
jeremy will have an immediate opinion
and i don't
this design did come from jeremy
really that's right isn't it
yeah i mean it was a yeah he wanted the
space between the double cam
all right well then we'll go with it
okay what am i seeing here
that opens the preferences field where
you so
right there's a forthcoming update to
the preferences dialog where
when
it's open you can open it and bring the
user's eye to a particular line item in
the dialog that's what this button will
use okay um to bring the attention to
the input field the list and change the
the actual value of dollar output size
limit
okay
you know i i really would love it if we
could do just a cosmetic update of the
preferences dialogue they look like they
come from sometime in the you know
before the
well that that's in the works it's in
process
okay that's good
all right okay anything else for the
output size limiter
do we want to can i
make one more comment about that font
color
yeah
um i mean it
it just feels like it's the you know
exact same thing i would get is if like
in current mathematic you know front end
i evaluated you know range of 10 to the
sixth
and then i changed the input and so it
did the undo grading
um
this thing
yeah that's a good point
yeah
maybe that's not bad because really the
output is disconnected from the input
yes
[Music]
in a different way
right and of course you have the gray
background which sort of
tells you it's a different sort of
disconnection
i think it's pretty okay so what happens
what happens if both are true if you
have the output limiter and you've
changed the input
then it will lighten even more i believe
easy enough to test
it didn't it didn't
that
that one the other one wasn't generated
in this session so it's it doesn't have
a connection
range of 10 to the sixth
you know it came up with that light
thing
which is
you know
it's not completely disconnected you
know
conceptually to people i think
you know i mean that's the current
output in the current session
you know even if it's not
you know stored locally in the notebook
look what's your suggestion i mean
you know we could give a slight color to
the tint to the background here but i
don't think that's a great idea i think
it's fine i mean i
you know this is a very temporary thing
this graying will happen only very
locally
this graying is not something you do no
no i'm not talking about the undo gray
no i i know that but okay i'm just
saying that that's you know when you did
that
right and right and you can and right if
you restore the six it'll know that
you've restored the original expression
even so
that's how ephemeral it is
well no that's not what i'm talking
about i know you're saying you see this
in an in something you didn't just
generate it because you know it if you
just generated it you see this lying in
a notebook and you say you might be
confused that it came from the graying
of something because of disconnection
from the input and i'm saying that's
going to be really rare because most
disconnection that comes from editing is
going to be extremely local
i agree with stephen on on that
particular point
i think it's going to be okay
let's let's
let's okay
i mean
good good thing to raise but i think
it's going to be okay
all right can we move on here
lou any last minute questions concerns i
think
no i think we've got a couple of solid
things to change and then
good to go
good stuff all right on we go map apply
nicely
thank you
guys
map apply as the
name for triple at sign
yep
seems like a good idea
right it's implemented um there there
there is i mean if you if you want to
review this documentation
um i also
there was this i noticed this weird
thing on apply where the option was only
documented an example so i added a note
if you want to remove that
the heads
oh that's crazy
no that it was only documented as an
example it's crazy it was probably done
in version one
right so if if you you know i don't know
if you want to review that
it looks fine
okay and then i mean the one real
question is do we want to use triple a
in formatting yeah that's a good
question
personally i would be
well the only reason to do that would be
for compatibility with earlier versions
right because if somebody has a piece of
code
that says hold of f triple at x
oh and now you're changing it to map
apply right well that's that's what you
said we should do
well yeah it will parse this map apply
now
right but if if you if you if you keep
it as triple at then right it'll work
equally
other other than parsing to the you know
it will evaluate equally in both right
right so if you have a wl file that has
triple hat in it or you know and you
feed it to an earlier version it will be
good
yep if you have a held expression with
triple a in it
no if you have a hell if you have a
literal map apply in it it will fail i
know but but also if you have a held
expression no not i understand if you
have
right as long as it's triple that it
will parse just fine i see i see what
you're saying i see what you're saying
so if you if you
exported it as a held expression the
serialized form will have triple a and
it'll be good
if we use
if we add the output format which we
haven't yet no what do you mean
no no no no no this is all good that
what you've got here i'm just yattering
to myself that
if in an earlier version
no if in this version
it came out with map apply the thing
you've got will not run on an earlier
version correct
i think that's okay but can we think it
through and try and i mean we should get
this in sooner rather than later i mean
let me point out that
both apply and map use their operators
in their output formatting
they do
yeah
well then this should as well
okay
yeah then this should as well then we
have no backward compatibility problem
and we're all good
yep
okay i guess my question would be if i
have a new front end
that knows about map apply
yep
and i connect to a kernel
that is older
no there's no problem there's no change
in the boxes the only changes
and the parsing oh okay
okay right now well i mean the one
difference you'll notice in the front
end is if you hover over that triple a
now stephen
oh i guess i guess that
that should now say map apply i i i
guess it's good
for some reason but that would be the
right thing for it to say and we'd be
all good yep
are there any other special
forms that do not translate that
translate into a special case of an
existing function
i think this is the only one
um
it's the only one i can think of off the
top of my head okay all right
all right
oh boy
right and and
so
you know
i'm not saying that there's necessarily
any issue here
uh but these are things sort of
i've noticed that i feel are a little
weird
um and you know we should at least
okay sort of okay so hold on let me just
understand something
uh is this the same as issues that i was
raising or is this orthogonal or is this
what what what is the relationship here
um i am not sure what issues you're
referring to so
these are these are less i came up
independently when i was reviewing
documentation written by ian
so in my view they are very related
to what you suggested to stephen last
week and ian has already created a
documentation page for a new function to
implement that
what what new function
um how do you call it ian ancestry i
think
oh this is the question of what what i
was talking about where
you have you want a certain number of
levels on the tree
exactly yes so why isn't that tree take
take
because this i mean we are talking about
we are not talking about sequence specs
in
well but but i'm saying it's levels
right i'm saying i want the top three
levels on this tree
or perhaps i want to drop the bottom two
levels on the tree
to me those seem like
tree take and tree drop
are you proposing for that
um so i think ian has created a new
function called ancestor3
that sounds
confusing to me but anyway okay so let's
make a random tree
okay so now what do you want to do
i'm not sure the code is in in the x
kernel yeah okay but what would it
roughly do
yes
say well okay go
ahead uh ian do you want to spring
ian hello
if you're talking we can't hear you uh
okay well perhaps he has some problem i
can explain so the idea would be to
specify either you just specify a
position spec of the nodes you want to
preserve and so you will preserve
everything above all those nodes
and it can be something like 3 level 3
and so it will be everything above 3
level three
i think it should be tree check and tree
dot because i think they're the obvious
you know things because i think that
they're
and and then that the spec is
essentially a level spec
okay so i admit
it's a position spec it's this
generalized form of position aspect in
which we cannot specify levels
but with drop what could what could we
return if we drop
the top of the tree
and and this relates to it guys comment
yeah
all right at least at least this first
comment about the heads
okay
this is the new proposed ancestor tree
um
yes two weeks ago you called it top
treetop
i just don't get the name ancestor tree
at all
i still don't get it at all
yeah yeah so ian was commenting recently
that
can you hear me now
yes
okay
okay so the operation you were wanting
was just
these
like the top three levels this is a more
general operation that's for any set of
positions
okay but what happens if i what happens
if i just have a swath in the middle of
the tree well that's so it preserves all
of the ancestors so that you still get
something connected and still something
that's a tree okay i would completely
not understand that from ancestor tree i
mean i'm thinking genealogy and i'm
thinking you know what's the ancestor of
all of the positions that you specify
right i mean that's what i understood
i'd never get it all right i agree when
you explain it that way it does make
some sense
it's true that this is a type of
function in which we usually have three
verbs
but we need ancestors we couldn't come
up with a verb which is good enough here
okay so the basic point is if i pick 13
you are going to give me
the
tree above 13.
reaching down to 13.
right so so and that'll be sort of the
minimal path so
three you know just
seven i get 31 but i don't get this
subtree over here
right okay
and you don't get 26
right right
where's 26 oh
i see
but how will i get those things
you specify 26 too
it's a list of positions
okay but if i want everything down to
level i want everything down to this
level how do i specify that
the second argument would be tree level
like some tree level spec and then
that's what it would do
but this is the sub trees on that level
so if i specify this level here this guy
is left out in the cold isn't it
yeah that that's not gonna work it's not
gonna work you say levels zero through
that and
look this is a really simple operation
okay the people are gonna want all the
time
just show me the top end levels in the
tree
i think something like tree level take
makes sense for that
fine
right this is an interesting operation
as well
but i think we need that
i don't know whether tree level take is
the right name given that tree level is
such a noun type form
well maybe it is
um right and i guess there's no negative
this doesn't make a difference yes but
tree drop
tree level drop
makes sense for the bottom of the tree
or was it that the drop would normally
rip
right but the take the the the take part
doesn't make sense for negative levels
right unlike take
where you can take the three from the
end and you still have an expression
right you can't take
the
top take
something like that it's the you know
you want
see the the typical thing christmas tree
takes
you know one of those things you put on
the top of a christmas tree i don't know
that
um
look here's what this is useful for this
is useful for discovery when you have
big trees
and you're not going to want to know oh
i've got element numbers such and such
blah blah blah all you know is you just
got a tree with a thousand elements i
want to see roughly what's going on in
it
okay does that make sense just like when
you have a big list you very often will
say take list comma 10 just to see the
first term i wants to see roughly what's
going on this is the same idea
but in three drop
we would get in general a list of trees
no i didn't mean that i mean i i it
doesn't make sense i i want to be able
to say look
i mean
that's horrible
what
i just want the
i don't like tree level tech i think
it's it's obscure
prune
no
that that suggests you're going in and
um
uh
you're gonna make a
topiary never mind
not necessarily i mean
um
we could have a we could have a topiary
function that goes in and uh
and edward scissorhands function
[Music]
okay so look tree
we need something i like the idea of
this function
but it is not serving the need that we
have for this function
wait a minute tree select
that's the operator form of tree select
that you're proposing to use there is
that correct
yep
it's a bit weird does this tree level
could it be used as an operator form
yeah tree level tree cases in tree
select can be used as operator forms in
like tree extract
this goes in the direction we were
discussing last week of the generalized
position specs and part specs
and so this is the attempt of having
symbolic
position specs
right
yes but i i'm
well i mean we've now gone off on this
tangent but the point i'm making is sort
of much more pedestrian right i have i
have two a span of two comma three there
right and there's this distinction which
it maybe isn't wrong maybe this is
exactly the right thing but
um right
if you if you extract
then you sort you keep the head
if you extract the span you keep the
head but if you tree extract a span
you sort of lose the head you get a list
of these individual
nodes
and that's weird
so
this is where it connects so for example
when you were mentioning three drop we
had the same problem do we return a list
of things or do we connect them back
with a single tree head now the problem
is that what do you put in the as
payload of that new route because
why should we put the old payload of the
old route
we are not interested in that anymore
it could be it could be an empty
route
that could be it's like
so you're saying
these
tree extract could be this could be far
down in the tree if i do a tree extract
on on on thing 11.
exactly we struck things from there
let's let's go 311 percent 11. let's do
20
what can i do here i can say 20
well let's do um 20
to 23.
what's that
no that's not going to work right the
the these are right these are these are
positions so you have like one through
six
right
at the first level
well i don't want one to something i
want something different i want
something no no the avail of the
available positions at level one of this
tree are one two three four five and six
corresponding so i have to go one
i i want to get down into here how do i
get down into into the big bushy part
you probably want three cases if you
want to specify the payload
right extract is a structural operation
it
doesn't care about the labels okay so
one
six
one
[Music]
two
and then let me go
one six one
what well sorry where did i want to do
that
one sec one only has one child
i know so i just went to one there is no
one six oh i'm sorry i should be six
okay so now we're down here
at level at this level
we've got these three and so what you're
saying is
if we were to put so that's what um
um
yes so so if we connected this this with
with a single root what should it be
seven
why why do we worry about seven now well
if
if
well because we want to main maintain
the correspondence between expressions
and trees
we have inspiration we would have a 4
not a 7 right
uh
yes we will have a four
in in this case but if that list had
been lists of disconnected positions
they may not have a common but if it's a
list of disconnected positions then we
get a list right if we're in the
multi-spec case we get
one tree for each spec
right that's that's how extract works if
you give it
you know a list of multiple specs you
get you know you get a list of results
one for each spec now that spec may or
may not preserve the head
right and and so what tree extract does
is it just keeps giving you arbitrarily
more and more nested lists
as you have more and more multi-part
specs
instead of having that property
sorry say that again i mean i i
this looks
um
let's see i'm sorry the the
i think it's hopeless to rejoin these
from something here i mean unless
what
my my claim is if you created the
corresponding nested
things
in in okay tree expression of percent 11
right is that going to give me that
okay right
so now i do the same exact thing right
yep
of that
what the heck did i get here
you got let's see so this is a prunery
of
right
it kept the four and then it gave the
you know the three arguments of the four
right so you that 13 17 16 became a 13
of 17 of 16 the 24 became 25 i get it so
so actually now i'm beginning to agree
with you that that the as if expression
thing isn't a totally silly thing is
there an argument against that
no
i'm fine with that
but
being able to get this
would just be a list here instead of a
span
right so if you if you if you replace
that one standard with just one
well what happens if i go one two three
yeah it's the same thing
you'll need percent percent or some such
you know percent
15 is that
right and and so
would we also do that for like tree
level tree cases
where
unlike span it's not necessarily the
children it could be any sub-tree
doesn't cases do something different
cases doesn't do this cases just returns
a list of the things that other cases
i'm saying when we use tree cases like
the operator form
you know it's like a symbolic spec
it's like it's like a multi-part spec
but the difference doesn't
span is always just at the one level
below but cases if you if you replace in
you're in a 14
if instead of a span there you did a
tree cases of something
okay you're do you're doing the the
three cases within tree extract yeah
just change the one through three to
three cases
that represents a list right so so this
should be like adding a new list around
that position
i don't know this is a weird thing where
you're using a selector you know we're
using an operator form of a selector
inside like that
[Music]
and that's exactly my comment
um
all right we're going to have to wrap
for today here i mean there's clearly a
lot more to talk about i do want to talk
about uh the charlotte suggests on the
live stream level limit tree
level limited tree
i think it needs to be simpler than that
it's like i just want to see
the top of this tree just want to get a
little bit into this tree
for an expression it will be shallow
that's what would show you the analogous
thing i mean maybe maybe we should have
a tree form that is you know
maybe we should make shallow work on
trees
that would at least give us
the display version that that actually
is not a bad idea to be able to say
shallow of the tree comma 10 or
something or comma 5 and have a form
where it has dot dots underneath it
that might serve the need that i have
there
you know what i'm saying
i think i also have a need for this
but it could be slightly more obscure
but that would seem like an obvious
thing to do is to just be able to sort
of eyeball what's in the tree by doing
shallow
what does a tree do if it gets really
really big does it have an output
limiter
the only output limiter we have is for
the number of
children
but what is it no you mean that's just
on a single level
but if the thing is a giant
piece of shrubbery what does it do
it's just a giant piece of shrubbery
i think we should think about output
limiters and i think we should think
about
maybe the right thing for a tree that
gets very large is for it to
automatically be like a tree outline
what is the tree outline
like the collapsible view
do we have no i think i think a graph
above a certain size like if you have
yeah it just goes a million it just
turns into a summary box i'm i'm well
aware of this since i generate large
graphs all the time yes that's correct
and graph plot will explicitly do it
yeah bob on livestream suggest treetop
of like three and i agree as an operator
form it's really quite nice
i mean treetop 3 comma 3 isn't totally
terrible as far as i'm concerned
i just worry about treetop being more
like an option
where you're saying you know where to
and actually no you know that's not
gonna happen because that's that's more
like
um the orientation is top and so on
um
i think i unfortunately have to go um so
uh
okay well we can pick this up next time
or maybe if there's a dedicated trees
meeting somewhere i think we probably
want a dedicated trees meeting this is
clearly we've got lots of stuff to talk
about here there they are it's a deeply
entwined subject so to speak
okay
okay good stuff thanks guys that's a
good thing all right thanks to folks on
livestream